okay so expectations can be a funny old
thing unfortunately because of the way
that the internet is it's almost
impossible to go into a movie these days
without having some preconceived notion
of what one should be and how you should
feel about it just in the same way that
i was told venom let there be carnage
was terrible and came out thinking it
was a lot of fun i was told june was an
action-packed sci-fi masterpiece that
was going to be the next lord of the
rings this kind of guided my perceptions
of how i thought the movie should be and
thus when i went to see it i ended up
leaving the film feeling a bit
disappointed the same thing happened
with tennit and though i initially came
out of the theater thinking meh after
revisiting it it's come to be a film
that i absolutely love 10 it feels like
a puzzle box with an almost infinite
amount of things to unpack from it but
going in with the mindset that it would
be inception with time travel in it it
was difficult to feel like it didn't
miss the mark now this mark was of
course set by me and this preconceived
notion was the scoreboard that i judged
not only tenant off but also june in my
original review for the film i praised
the cinematography and world building
but i also said that i felt let down by
the movie as it came across like it was
just setting up a sequel that we might
not even get now at the time of making
that review a sequel hadn't been
announced but honestly knowing that one
is coming is great news even if i feel
that it was a bit misguided by warner
bros not to film things back to back i
criticized it and said that those star
wars clearly took elements from it it
actually adapted things better to a
movie and the typical 3x structure i
didn't even end up giving the movie a
score on my review because i just didn't
really know how i felt about the entire
thing and because of these reasons you
can kind of see where my head sat in
terms of the film because of the
aforementioned aspects i left the cinema
feeling like this was a big misstep but
after revisiting the movie i have to
admit something i was wrong you were
what i said i said i was wrong you were
worried look i'm wrong i've said i'm
wrong i'm wrong
now strangely enough the thing that made
me appreciate this movie even more was
actually the 1984 version by david lynch
over the weekend i picked up the brand
new 4k release of it and if you enjoyed
denny's adaptation then i definitely
recommend that you go and pick it up too
it's got a lot of the same scenes in it
but also some alternate ones in its own
style that i think will make you
appreciate this one even more due to how
it adapts the material in its own way i
really like the 1984 film and though
some elements are a bit dated i think it
acts as a great companion to this movie
if there's things that you don't
understand or moments that you got lost
on it'll help clear that all up and it
just adds a fuller feeling to this
entire universe now why i think the two
are worth viewing it's because that
movie feels like your typical 1980s
sci-fi fantasy film with heavy
exposition whereas the 2021 version is
an experience a lot of the story beats
and character motivations are very much
laid in the subtext and dune isn't here
to spell things out it's here to engross
you and give you somewhat of a sensory
experience so that you feel like you're
lost in a space opera much like the
characters it really must be said that
you should go and see this film in imax
as the sound stage and giant image
definitely sucks you into the movie and
it makes the visuals even more
breathtaking you really get pulled into
the worlds and seeing the vast sunsets
towering monuments and barren halls
becomes all the more atmospheric upon
seeing it the way that it was intended
to be viewed now i kind of want to
revisit that star wars comparison as
it's one of the things i got the most
heat for and though i told people not to
get sand in their vagina i think they
have a point however in order to discuss
it i need to talk about spoilers so if
you haven't seen the movie then you
should shield yourself from the next
part of the video i will also be hinting
at minor book developments too so if
you're someone who just doesn't want to
know anything you have been warned now
one thing i got slam for in my review
was comparing the film to a new hope
even though i clearly said that lucas
took from june i still had people
complaining that i'd even mentioned it
in the same breath and that i was stupid
for comparing the two i obviously know
june came first as i said it in my
review and as lucas admitted to basing
star wars upon it i thought it was a
fine comparison to make but hey it's the
internet and i guess not now what i
caught spice for is that i said though
there are similar plot elements across
both pieces a new hope adapted said
material better to a three-act structure
it had a hero whose family was taken
away from him and he trained to become
adept in the ways of a mystical magic
whilst fighting against a dark force in
the universe however what i slam dune
for is that its final act didn't feel
like a triumphant one and instead of the
hero defeating the dark side in a blaze
of glory paul very much had to retreat
into the desert to gather his strength
in numbers i felt this was a bit of a
dour note to end a movie on and though
the book takes this exact same path i
did say that i think they could have
changed up the novel several books that
have been adapted to film tend to take
what works about the source material fit
it to a three-act structure and then
have a big blowout between the forces of
good and evil though lots of people have
said that the fellowship of the rings is
similar to june i have to disagree as i
think the latter is a lot more
understated whereas the former isn't
though both are very close to their
literary counterparts they are doing
different things and i actually think
that june is closer to season one of
game of thrones than it is to any of
tolkien's work in the first season we
watched as the houses all came together
in order to seemingly strengthen the
empire or well the kingdoms however game
of thrones season one was very much
about betrayal and it culminated in ned
stark being killed which put his
children on a path of retreat before
they enacted their revenge that's very
much what june is about and in it we see
the fall of an empire watch the death of
a father and then ortiz the idea that
the family will get its revenge after
rebuilding in the wilderness much like
ned was called into a position to be the
king's hand away from his home the
atreides are called to arrakis much like
how ua betrays the family ned is
betrayed too and both the father figures
are killed sadly both ned and leto know
that something is up with the so-called
promotion that they've been given but
they're bound by their duty to stay in
the place they've been summoned to and
this ultimately leads to their deaths
june thematically is meant to be a
tragedy and not going into the movie
with this mind state made me believe
that it should be a certain way when
really it was meant to be the opposite
now before you start i have read june
but it was a good 15 years ago and i
think that it's had so many movies that
have taken things from it and actually
forgotten what made june june not to
spoil too much of what's to come but
paula tradies isn't really the
stereotypical hero that you might think
if you've only seen this movie he's
painting out as somewhat of a savior
figure but there's far more complexity
to his character than just being the
next messiah as we progress into the
story i think we'll very much question
what it means to be a hero and this is
actually hinted at with the movie's
ending throughout the film we watch as
he has visions of training with james
but come the end of the movie he kills
the character before they can ever come
to fruition now i have seen people say
that they think he's simply seeing
things through the eyes of channy but
either way it shows he's a different
kind of hero to what we've seen in other
movies most heroes would have found a
way to cheat the rules and have spared
james but paul kills him because he
knows that it will provide him with
access to an army so that he can get
revenge it's a really complicated ending
and though it's seen as a victory paul
does somewhat lose himself in carrying
out the actions that he does
this is kind of why i got dune wrong i
went in with different expectations some
of the wrong interpretations and overall
just misjudged what the movie was trying
to put across this is an epic space
opera that's laced with a lot of subtext
and outstanding visuals that makes it a
completely immersive experience the film
is meant to be viewed as a tragedy and
it's also a warning to not only the
fallacy of hero worship but also the
downfall that blind duty can lead to
after re-watching june i've gained a new
appreciation for it and if you're
someone who went in disappointed then i
recommend that you rewatch the movie and
also give the 1984 version a watch i am
really hyped for the sequel and it's
great to see the movie making money at
the box office especially with all the
factors riding against it the movie not
only dropped on hbo max but it also
leaked with hd copies online everywhere
the week before it was available on the
streaming service so it's pretty
impressive that it's still doing as well
as it is it's definitely going to be a
film i revisit and if this video does
well then i've made money from saying i
didn't like it and then money from
saying i did so i got you you sucker
no i'm just kidding and there have been
several films that have changed in my
mind over time the more that i've
watched them i didn't actually like
casino royale or batman begins the first
time that i saw them but looking back on
those movies are some of the best
interpretations of those classic
characters ever so yeah things can
change and i'd also love to know if you
hated the movie and now liked it liked
it and now hate it and if you liked it
and still like it and so on and so forth
all opinions are valid and as someone
who's done a 180 on the movie i'm more
than happy to have people disagree with
me just try and keep the conversation
civil tickets now because of this i'll
give you a thank you and enter you into
a competition in which you are giving
away three copies of the phase three mcu
box set on the 30th of october all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the film we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
last ones are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want to see our
initial opinion and breakdown of the
movie then make sure you check out our
ending explained which will be linked on
screen right now if not then thank you
for sitting through this video i hope
you've had a good one i love you and
i'll see you on the next one if you
still like me and without the way thanks
for checking this out enjoy the rest of
your week peace